Transcriber: Yara Kadoon
المدقّق: Aya Ashraf
مرحباً، يعطيكم العافية.
عندما تفقد جزءاً منك..
فإن هذا لايعني أنك فقدت الحياة والأمل.
هذه إشارة تثبت مدى إيمانك وحبك..
للشيء الذي تمارسه في الحياة.
نحن نعيش ظروف تختلف عن جميع الناس.
أنا علاء الدالي، ولدتُ في مدينة رفح 1997.
في ذلك الوقت الذي ولدتُ فيه..
كان وضع عائلتي وظروفنا المالية صعبة جداً.
كنا نتنقل من منزل إلى آخر.
في عمر السنة كان لدي تقوس في ساقيّ.
أمي أخذتني إلى العيادة،
أخبرها الطبيب بمدى حاجتي للرعاية والتغذية.
أمي ذهبت إلى المنزل باكية.
قالت لأبي: يجب أن تبحث عن عمل،
الفتى حالته خطرة للغاية.
أبي كان رافضاً لفكرة العمل عند أي شخص آخر،
لأنه كان صاحب شركة أثاث.
أمي قالت له: إذا لم تجد عملًا،
سأذهب لمنزل عائلتي.
تحرك أبي ووجد عملًا.
و بدأت أمي تهتم بتغذيتي وصحتي.
وأنا بعمر ال5 سنوات، تحسن وضعنا المادي.
أبي عمل بتجارة كبيرة واشترى لي أول دراجة.
هذه الدراجة غيرت تفكيري بالحياة بشكل كبير.
طلب مني ابن عمي أن أعيره دراجتي؛
ليشارك في المسابقة المدرسية.
أخذها، و قال لي: سأحصل على المركز الأول.
لكنه حصل على المركز السابع،
قلت له لا تحزن،
سأحصل أنا على المركز الأول من أجلك.
ومن هنا بدأت مسيرتي مع الدراجة.
بدأت التدرب، أردت أن أكون ذاك الصبي..
الذي يحصل على المركز الأول،
ويفوز بالميدالية الذهبية.
وأنا بعمر ال8 سنوات تدهور وضع أبي من جديد.
و سُجِن على ذمة مالية.
واضطررت في هذا الوقت أن أعمل
في بيع الخضار، و تحميل البضاعة،
وعملت حتى في تنظيف المجاري.
أردت أن أعيل أمي وإخوتي،
وبنفس الوقت أريد أن أحافظ على حلمي
و دراجتي، و أحافظ على دراستي.
ثلاثة أشياء يجب على علاء أن يحافظ عليها.
من البيت إلى المدرسة،
ومن المدرسة إلى العمل.
ومن العمل إلى دراجتي.
ودراجتي ترافقني في جميع تفاصيل حياتي.
عندما كنت في المدرسة الإعدادية،
كانت سنة المراكز.
كانت أول مشاركة لي في أول سباق.
حصلت على المركز الثالث.
وعندها بدأت أشارك،
وأتابع كل ما يتعلق
برياضة الدراجات الهوائية.
ثم دخلت المدرسة الثانوية،
وقررت أن أدخل كلية باور لصيانة التكييف.
وبنفس الوقت كنت أرغب بأن أكون
بطل الناشئين في محافظة رفح.
شاركت، ودخلت المسابقة،
وكنت الأول على الناشئين في أندية رفح.
وهنا بدأت مسيرتي تكبر، وحلمي يكبر معي.
و بنفس الوقت عملي كان يرافقني؛
لأن وضعنا كان صعبًا جدًا.
عملت في شركة، وتعلمت صنعة.
و أصبحت مسؤولًا عن عمال.
وأصبح لدي خبرة كبيرة،
أكثر من ناس عملوا لفترة أطول
بهذا المجال.
وكنت بعد مغادرة عملي أتدرب على دراجتي،
و أمارس الرياضة.
الغطس، وكرة القدم، والجري.
وهذا زاد من لياقتي البدنية.
وأصبحت أقطع مع دراجتي مسافات أكبر،
لأن حلمي أن أصبح بطل على مستوى وطني.
تدهور وضع أبي،
وأصبح علي أن أعمل وأساعد في مصروف البيت.
لسد الديون.
و هذه مسؤوليتي، وبنفس الوقت
لم أستسلم ولم أتراجع عن مسابقاتي.
دخلت عدة مشاركات ومسابقات،
وحصلت على الكثير من المراكز.
وفي ذلك الوقت، كان حدث هو الأول من نوعه.
بطولة الناشئين على مستوى محافظات الوطن:
غزة والضفة، والمسافة 30 كيلومتر.
شاركت وأخذت المركز الأول.
(تصفيق)
وبدأت أترشح لمسابقة خارج الوطن.
ولكن للأسف..
الحصار والمعابر لم تعطني الفرصة لأشارك.
وأنا لم أتوقف.
سنة 2017 كنت أتدرب على دراجتي بشكل أكبر.
لمسافة 70 كيلو.
وبدأت في غزة بطولة اليابان،
سباق طوكيو.
شاركت وحصلت أيضًا على المركز الأول
على الناشئين،
والمركز الثالث على جميع الفئات في فلسطين.
(تصفيق)
ثم ترشحت للمشاركة في مسابقة في إندونيسيا.
وكانت هذه أول مرة يعترف الاتحاد الآسيوي
باتحاد فلسطين.
كنت أنا واحد من 3 دراجين على مستوى فلسطين.
وكانت المسافة 30 كيلو.
وأنا كنت أتدرب على 120 كيلو.
بتاريخ 30/3/2018
(تصفيق)
كان يوم مسيرات العودة الكبرى.. يوم الأرض.
دعاني الاتحاد لأشارك في هذه المشاركة.
وذهبت مرتديًا زيّي و بدراجتي.
لأشارك في هذا المسير السلمي.
هل تعرفون ما معنى “سلمي”؟
تم استهداف ساقي اليمنى بطلق متفجر.
و لم أشعر بشيء.
الكل كان ينظر إلي.
كانوا يصرخون: علاء أُصيب!
وأنا أقول: كفاكم مزاحاً! إلى أن سقطت.
“علاء أصيب! ”
وأنا أقول لهم: لا أنا في كابوس، هذا حلم.
أغمى علي.
واستيقظت لأجد نفسي في المستشفى.
أول شيء سألت عنه كان دراجتي.
قالوا لي: ارتاح أنت مصاب، وإصابتك خطيرة.
وأنا مُصر على أن هذا كابوس.
قلت لهم: أريد دراجتي!
و ضمدوا لي قدمي، أنا عندي بطولة!
و نهضت بكل قوّتي.
و غبت عن الوعي؛ لأنه كان لدي نزيف.
انخفض ضغط دمي إلى 3.
دخلت إلى العمليات؛ لإيقاف هذا النزيف.
ولوصل الشرايين، ولتركيب بلاتين.
ولكن كل هذه العمليات لم تنجح.
حاول الاتحاد أن يسفرني للعلاج،
ولكن الاحتلال رفض.
و ساءت حالتي، وتخطت درجة حرارتي الأربعين.
وازدادت قدمي سوءًا، وكان الألم فظيع جدًا.
واضطررت في ذاك الوقت أن آخذ قرار البتر.
بتر ساقي.
كنت أفكر طوال الوقت بدراجتي وبطولتي،
والميدالية الذهبية لأهلي ولفلسطين.
ولكن هذا حلم، كما حدثتكم في البداية.
عندما تفقد جزءًا منك،
فإن هذا لايعني أنك فقدت الحياة والأمل.
لأن إيمانك يصنع منك إرادة أقوى من قبل.
(تصفيق)
خرجت من المستشفى.
أول شيء طلبته هو أن أركب دراجتي هذه.
بقدم واحدة.
حاولت، ووقعت. حاولت، ونجحت.
وبدأت قصتي تظهر في الإعلام.
تواصل معي الاتحاد الآسيوي.
اتحاد الباراليمبك، وهو اتحاد للمعاقين.
للمشاركة في سباق في إندونيسيا للمعاقين.
وكانت المسافة 10 كيلو.
و كنت أتدرب عليها بشكل قوي.
وقطعت العشرة كيلو بعشرين دقيقة.
بقدم واحدة.
وكان من ضمن هذه المشاركة
أن أحصل على طرف صناعي،
وأحصل على دراجة دولية، ورقم دولي.
ولكن نحن في غزة..
حصار ومعابر لم تمكنني من المشاركة.
وأنا لم أتوقف.
هنا قررت تشكيل فريق
لمبتوري الأقدام في غزة.
وهذا الفريق كان الأول في الوطن العربي.
شكلت فريق درّاجو البتر، ونجحت.
ومسؤوليتي تجاه هذا الفريق
أن أبحث عن مصدر تمويل.
عدة محاولات،
ولكن لم أنجح.
ولكن نجحت بتشكيل اتحاد،
وأخذ اعتراف دولي، ومن هنا..
بدأت قصة علاء تظهر في الإعلام بشكل أكبر.
ووصلت قصتي للعالم.
تواصل معي مدير
الاتحاد العالمي للدراجات الهوائية.
قال لي: علاء، سأساعدك في تكوين هذا الفريق.
وسأساعدك للسفر إلى فرنسا؛
لتركيب طرف صناعي،
ولتتدرب، ولتشارك في مشاركات دولية.
وأنا الآن بطريقي لمشاركات دولية،
حتى أحصل على رقم دولي.
وأشارك في بطولة العالم، بطولة اليابان.
وإن شاء الله سوف أفوز بالمركز الأول.
و أرفع علم فلسطين فوق أكتافي.
و أقول لأمي وعائلتي:
أنا قادر أن أكون طالما أتنفس.
أنا قادر أن أكون في هذه الحياة.
المهم هو الإرادة والإيمان،
ستجعلك تجتاز كل هذه التحديات.
أنا علاء الدالي، ولدت جديدًا مع تحدى كبير.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)